welcome back to sunday night in america
apologies to anyone who took seriously
president biden's commission to study
the supreme court this commission you
may recall was born of political
convenience during the 2020 presidential
campaign progressives were demanding the
court be expanded they wanted to dilute
what they believed to be a conservative
majority by adding more progressive
justices they wanted to get politics out
of the supreme court by adding more
political justices
it was and remains a terrible idea
but modern political leaders are too
afraid of the base to disagree with the
base
biden didn't want to answer the question
on packing the court during the campaign
so he punted
and said he would form a commission
the commission now has some modest
proposals none of which will ever be
enacted
i don't have the credentials to be on a
commission as august as that one nor do
i like footnotes but i do have some
ideas of my own to republicans think
about the following justices
brennan blackman stevens warren and
suitor
what do they have in common
all were liberal members of the court
put on the bench
by republican presidents
so my advice to republicans is do a
better job of vetting the judicial
philosophy of nominees before you
elevate them to the high court
to the contrary can you name a single
justice
put on the supreme court during your
lifetime by a democrat president who
surprised you
with his or her conservatism
to the media
just try to at least fake being fair
the way you frame issues and court
decisions is overtly partisan it sows
the seeds of discord in our country it
treats serious and complex legal issues
with a provocative headline and a tweet
according to the media conservatives
just want to restrict and deny and limit
while liberal judges they want to expand
and empower and liberate
the words they use prove their bias and
their bias explains their diminished
role in our country and the diminished
view of the court
by the public
to us
what do we want from the court
do we want fairness or just a decision
we agree with
do we want impartiality
or a certain desired result
can we separate what the law is
from what we want it to be
do we have the discipline to win the
debate or do we just want to win the
supreme court vote
we don't need more or fewer justices we
don't need to set their docket or their
retirement decisions
we need a court that understands its
role
in our tripartite system
justices who can disagree with and even
dissent from
even their own personal feelings
and we need to elevate the virtue of
fairness
and we don't need a commission for any
of that hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else